jean pierre melville votre film le
cercle rouge est en train de devenir il
n'a pas terminé son exclusivité
mais il est déjà le film de 70 qui a eu
le plus de spectateurs
or en 70 et s'est produit un phénomène
qui ne s'était pas passé depuis douze
ans c'est à dire que le nombre d'entrées
dans les salles a remonté par rapport à
60 alors je voulais vous poser une
question est ce que le cinéma va mieux
non pas du tout va plus mal que jamais
ce grand nombre de spectateurs dont vous
parlez ne s'est disputé que cinq films
en vérité c'est à dire que les records
de de recettes sont battus sur un tout
petit nombre d'ouvragés mais que la
quasi totalité des films entrepris
réalisé en france cette année ont été de
mauvaise affaire on a l'impression
justement qu aux états unis et même en
italie un renouveau du cinéma
alors qu'en france les films qui ont
marché sont des policiers quand même
assez classique
alors que se passe-t-il pourquoi n'y
at-il pas c'est la même évolution dans
le cinéma français
je crois que ce que l'on a appelé le
phénomène de la nouvelle vague
à tort puisque la nouvelle vague n'a
existé que pendant trois ans 59 60 60 61
et 61 62 n'a pas formé contrairement à
ce qu'on imaginait à ce moment là une
nouvelle école de cinéastes français
mais a contribué énormément à la
création d'une école du cinéma américain
qui a pris certaines recettes godard de
plus faux d'alain resnais pour en faire
maintenant un cinéma moderne
spécifiquement américain qui ne doit
plus rien au cinéma français qu'il l'a
inspiré et qui leur permet de faire des
films absolument admirable je crois que
le cinéma français souffrent aussi
d'autres choses
c'est à dire d'une réglementation
officielle on considère ce n'est pas un
métier majeurs alors on l'a mis sous
tutelle et tout le monde croit que
cinéma français vit de subventions ce
qui est complètement faux
le cinéma français sont auto financier
jamais le cinéma français n'a pris un
souhait l'état mais on lui prend à la
source c'est-à-dire à la caisse du
cinéma beaucoup d'argent qu'on ne lui
rend pas toujours c'est à dire que le
producteur du cercle rouge par exemple
sera puni sera pénalisé il a fait un
film qui marche trop bien on ne lui
donnera donc pas toutes les aides au
cinéma à laquelle il a droit et
s'attelle au cinéma qui lui revient
absolument puisque c'est son l'argent
qu'on a pris dans la caisse du cinéma on
la donnera à une commission chargée de
d'établir des privilèges c'est à dire de
distribuer ce que l'on appelle une
avance sur recette à des très jeunes
cinéastes inexpérimentés ou à des moins
jeunes cinéastes très bien vu par la
commission de avance sur recette et on a
tout faussé
je m'adresse si vous permettez à travers
votre micro à travers votre caméra me
suis assoupi et notre grand maître à
tous pour lui dire une chose tout
repenser complètement le problème du
cinéma
laissez-le être ce qu'une boîte être
c'est-à-dire un art absolument libre de
tout